auf einem flohmarkt tauchte ihr
künstlerisches werk auf rund 100.000
fotos ob zum teil unentwickelten
filmrollen mit aufnahmen aus new york
und chicago
vivian maier hatte sie von 1950 bis 2009
als sie mit 83 jahren starb aufgenommen
john maloof stadthistoriker und
glücklicher entdecker des verborgenen
bild schatzes widmet sich in der
dokumentation finding vivian maier
gemeinsam mit charly cisco der suche
nach der identität der unbekannten
künstlerin
lili in myra geborene new yorkerin die
zeitlebens als kindermädchen arbeitete
immer mit der kamera in der hand maloof
lässt die von ihr betreuten kinder
längst erwachsen und teilweise schon
fortgeschrittenen alters von ihrer
exzentrischen nanny berichten
mayer zog mit einer wachsenden zahl von
kisten in denen sie fotografien
dokumente und zeitungen aufbewahrte von
familie zu familie ihre bilder hielt sie
immer unter verschluss
unter den fotografien sind auch selbst
porträts von meyer die oftmals hinter
ihrer um den hals hängen kamera
verschwand
mit ihrem blick für die besondere
situation gelang es ihr den zeitgeist
einzufangen der auf den straßen new
yorks und chicagos herr
steinmeier wird posthum in einem atemzug
mit dem bedeutendsten straßen fotografen
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts genannt
eindeutig ist jedoch dass es bei ihren
schnappschüssen nicht um das bewahren
von augenblicken ging sondern um das
erfassen der welt aus ihrer perspektive